- Hey everyone, Sal Khan
here from Khan Academy.
Welcome to our daily homeroom live stream.
If it's your first time and
are wondering what is this?
This is a live stream
that we started doing
every day since school
closure started happening
'cause we realize as a not
for profit with a mission
of free world class education
for anyone anywhere,
we have a role to step up.
It's our duty to step up to
support teachers, parents,
and students as we all
navigate through this crisis.
And so we've been trying
to put as many supports out
as possible teacher
webinars, parent webinars,
(mumbles) class schedules,
frameworks for learning plans
for students, and also this homeroom.
And this is a way to stay connected
in times of social distancing
and to just talk about interesting things.
Many of which might be
related to the crisis
or whatever else is on folks' mind.
I do like to remind folks as I just did,
that we are not for profit
and we can only exist through
philanthropic donations.
So if you're in a position to do so
please think about donating,
we were running at a deficit
even before the crisis
and now we're seeing about two and a half
to three times the
traffic we normally see,
and you could imagine that
plus all of the other programs
and content we're trying to accelerate
are only making our costs go up higher.
I do wanna give a special thanks
to several corporate
partners that stepped up
over the last couple of
weeks when they realized
how big the need was to support everyone
on the education front for COVID.
Special thanks to Bank
of America, Google.org,
Fastly, AT&T and Novartis.
They've made a huge difference,
but we still are running at a deficit.
So any more help from either corporations
or individuals is very,
very much appreciated.
So with that we'll get into
the heart of this live stream
and sometimes we have guests
and sometimes we don't
or I guess you could say
today I am the guest.
And so we could treat
this livestream as really
just a ask Sal anything so
you can get on the Facebook
and YouTube message boards
and literally ask me anything
and I have team members
that are helping me
surface interesting questions.
But we also said that
given that this is the end
of Teacher Appreciation Week
that we wanna make sure
teachers feel supported
especially as they're
all trying to navigate
this world of distance
learning or making videos.
And so I'm also happy to
answer questions for teachers
who are wondering what
are tips we might have
for making content, for making videos
and what are the tools we have?
So feel free to put those questions in.
I already have a question from Facebook
Jay is asking,
"I must admit that I would be happy
if I just knew the name of the tablet
that Sal uses to present.
That is the biggest challenge
when teaching remotely.
I cannot tell you how many
times teachers have said,
if only we had tablets like Sal uses."
All right I will tell you
the name of the tablet
I actually have it right over here,
and I'm not normally
about product endorsement.
So I'm not sure if this is
the best tablet out there
or what but it's definitely met my needs.
So let's see this is the
Intuos Pro Medium Pen Tablet.
I think it costs 100 or
$200, it looks like this,
and it will come with a pen that...
Whoops I'm pressing buttons on it,
I hope (mumbles)...
It comes with a pen that looks like this.
This camera is kind of a reverse mode.
So there you go.
So that is the tablet and I
think the cost really increases
as you go from the small,
to the medium, to the large.
For many years at Khan Academy
I had the small version,
which was I think was $70,
and you can go pretty far with that.
So yeah hopefully that is useful
and obviously this is useful.
Tablets like this are useful
for making Khan Academy style videos.
And I actually use a
tablet like that with a pen
and I use Camtasia to record my screen
and this is the microphone that I have.
This is a Samson...
And once again,
I'm sure there's other good microphones
let's see Samson CO3U,
I just realized it
wouldn't make do much good
if I'm reading the model number
when my mouth is on the
other side of the microphone.
But just with that and Camtasia
you can make exactly the
types of videos I make.
And obviously, this is
useful for all of y'all
who are also doing live,
Zoom or Google Hangout
type sessions as well 'cause
you can share your screen
and then use your art program.
Oh, and I use SketchBook
Pro for the art program,
but you could use others.
I like to just use something
that's quite responsive.
Some of the art programs
that get super fancy
there's a little bit of a
lag and that bothers me.
So that's what I try to do,
and I've been working with some teachers
running some live sessions as well.
And so I use the exact same tools for that
where I can share my screen
and share the art program.
I will say a low tech hack
for the live sessions,
and actually in theory you could do this
for your videos as well,
is those those small whiteboards
that we have students
do their problem on,
you can literally just have one of those
and write with a with a marker.
I've actually found that
to be reasonably good
especially for the kind
of the live sessions
when you're trying to work with students.
So from YouTube Matthew Masters asks,
"Sal, do you think there
will always be a place
for classroom learning
or will online learning
eventually become the standard?"
Simple answer is yes I think
there will always be a place
for classroom learning,
or I hope there will always be a place
for classroom learning.
Especially for students who
haven't reached adulthood.
So I would say for K through 12 for sure,
because in theory yes students could learn
a lot of the academic skills
potentially on their own time and pace,
on things like Khan Academy,
and or you can have Zoom sessions
and you can have this kind
of distance type of learning,
but that's only part of what
really makes the school
experience powerful.
There is a whole other level
of having incredible teacher mentors,
being able to form bonds with them,
being able to do
extracurricular activities,
all of the socialization
that goes on in school,
knowing how to work in groups,
knowing when to communicate,
when not to communicate, know
how to get your point across.
These are all super important skills
that you'll never see on
any standardized test,
but we all know that
they're very, very important
for overall life and success.
So, I've always said If I had to pick
between an amazing teacher
and amazing technology
I would pick the amazing
teacher every time
and I would prefer to have
that amazing teacher in person,
so we should definitely strive for that.
And I think I would want
it for my own children
and frankly all children.
And so I think the interesting question
over the COVID crisis is,
how do we get as close to that as possible
given the constraints that
we have of social distancing?
And then longer term,
hopefully when we get out of
this crisis sooner than later.
How do we leverage the
best of both worlds?
So I think hopefully we're
gonna go back to school,
kids are gonna be to
get that socialization,
they're gonna be back in those classrooms
with their amazing teachers,
but then everyone has
built a stronger muscle
for sometimes maybe the
distance learning does work
maybe over summers, maybe over
breaks, maybe after school.
It doesn't have to just be
between the teachers and the students,
it could be older students
and younger students
or it could be the peers working together,
so I think that would be a good takeaway
from this whole process.
I think higher education,
there are some real questions.
I loved my college experience,
I loved sitting in the
dorm and pontificating
about philosophical questions
and I met my wife and many of
my best friends in college.
So I definitely think that was
a very valuable experience,
but there's a lot of students
who, there's huge trade offs.
They need to help support their families,
they might want you to start make money
while they're in college,
and so I think in cases like that
when just you have more of adult learners,
I think there will always be a place
for the in person college experience.
But I can imagine some adult learners
decide that that's not for them
and that they could still
get their college degree
and learn all the material,
but do it at their own time and pace
and be a little bit more flexible
because maybe they hold a job
or they have to support their
family and things like that.
So, my personal view is I
hope we only double down
on the physical experience
but leverage some of the tools
we're all exploring with
a little bit more as well.
So from Facebook, Jaya Gupta asks,
"How can I become a good teacher?
Because I'm teaching my students,
but some students are
not taking it seriously.
Please tell me dear sir, what to do."
Jaya, I won't pretend like
I have all of the answers.
And I in the Khan Academy journey
I've done a certain flavor of teaching,
but there's a whole other
dimension of teaching
which you and many other amazing teachers
are doing on a day to day basis
that I think I can learn a ton from y'all
versus the other way around.
My best advice, though, is try to make it
as interactive as possible,
and when you do that think about it.
And this actually goes
to the earlier question
about in person versus digital.
I think there'll always
be a place for in person,
but we should always be
conscientious of what maybe digital,
or online, or software,
or videos could do.
So, if you're just giving a
lecture for 10 minutes straight
in theory, that could happen over a video.
And so if that could happen over video
then maybe it should happen over video,
but then that liberates
you to do something else.
And it's not like all of a
sudden there's nothing to do,
you could have a Socratic dialogue,
you could have a simulation,
you could have a project,
you could put a problem up on the board
that's a little bit more challenging
and have the students
struggle with it a little bit.
Have them break into groups
and try to come up with their own answers,
and then present it and you're
walking around nudging them,
giving them a little hint
for the ones that get stuck.
So I think there's a huge opportunity
for that classroom to just interact
with more with each other.
Those students that
you might be describing
whose eyes are glazed over a little bit,
I generally think if
you told that student,
"Hey, pair up with the person next to you
or form a group of three
or four, here's a puzzle,
here's an interesting challenge,
here's a philosophical question."
To ponder, their eyes will
light up and in a lot of ways
it can take a little bit
of the burden off of you.
I've definitely sat in
front of a classroom
of students and tried to
teach them and you're like,
"What are they thinking?
They're staring at me, I
have to be on for the entire
40, 50 minutes."
It's incredibly draining both
physically and emotionally,
and as soon as you kind of get out
of that kinda being
the person on the stage
so to speak and then you're
kind of with the students
and you're tackling
something with them together.
It actually allows you to
not have to feel as on,
which I've actually personally found good.
People might be surprised to hear,
I'm very much an introvert I
can pretend to be an extrovert
(laughs) like I do on this live stream,
but I recharge my energy
when I'm having one on one
conversations with people,
when I'm able to go a little bit deeper,
when I have a little bit more quiet time.
And so for me it's incredibly draining
to be on for long periods of time,
but it's very energizing if
I can sit next to a student
and work with them that way.
So those are my tips make it
as interactive as possible,
Have the students help each other,
and things like Socratic
dialogue, simulations, games,
challenging, make it active.
I think would move everything
in the right direction.
So from Facebook Alicia Moody says,
"The hardest part of
this as a math teacher
is supporting my most struggling students
who are already behind.
I teach high schoolers,
some of whom have critical thinking skills
closer to fourth to sixth grade.
What are your favorite
supports for students
struggling with connecting
the abstractions of algebra with real life
when they don't have much
foundational number sense,
any online games or
basics Focused activities
targeted towards teens?"
Alicia or Alicia,
You're asking a central question.
And this is something we think
a lot about at Khan Academy
because you've probably
heard me talk about it,
and the traditional model
kids keep moving forward,
they get to C on one test a D on another,
that 20% that 30% gap,
those things accumulate
and then they get to your classroom,
and as you mentioned
they're kind of operating
at a...
At least they're ready for the math
at a fourth through sixth grade level.
So there's a couple things we've done,
we've seen and really this is
learning from other teachers,
we've seen teachers
especially teachers who
are serving students
who might be many grade levels behind
who haven't maybe had
gotten all the supports
they might need to start
them at the beginning.
So, I'll tell you what you could do today
and then I'll tell you
what I hope you can do
in about two months,
'cause we're working on
some things that I think
will help solve this problem.
So today, I would actually
have those students
start on our arithmetic course
and just go from the beginning,
from one plus one straight
through the arithmetic course.
And they can use course challenges
and unit test to accelerate.
So what I would suggest
is have those students
start with the course challenge
on the arithmetic course,
and then the stuff they
got right, that's great,
and then the stuff they got wrong
they can go into those
units and remediate.
And if they're getting 70,
80% on the course challenge
they should keep taking it,
and then they'll get to be able to show
the mastery on those skills,
and then they can go back and get mastery
on the things that they
need to fill in those gaps.
And then they should do the same thing
with our pre algebra course,
and if they do that it's kind
of going slow to go fast,
they're gonna have a
very strong foundation,
they're actually gonna build
a lot of their confidence
and you're gonna have a lot more fluency,
and they're gonna be ready
for your algebra class.
A lot of times when a student
in an algebra class says,
"Hey, teacher, when am I
gonna need this in life?"
I think they might be asking
when are they gonna need it,
but it also might be a defense mechanism.
In some ways they're trying
to protect their self-esteem
that this doesn't matter,
because they're lost, they
have a gap in decimals,
they have a gap in negative numbers,
and all of a sudden there's
an equation on the board
that has negative numbers and decimals
and even if they're aware
that they have those gaps
they might be embarrassed
'cause they know it was fourth
or fifth grade material.
And so I think the best
way to short circuit that,
"Hey teacher when am I
gonna need to know this?"
is by making sure kids have that fluency
and that strong foundation
from the beginning
and they have as few gaps as possible.
And the example I show
is that when you're in PE
class, when I was in ninth grade
and I wasn't the strongest
basketball player,
but I didn't ask the coach,
"Hey coach, when am I
going to have to throw
a orange round ball into
a 10 foot hoop in life,
when do I need to know this?"
And the reason why I didn't ask that
is even though I wasn't the best player
I was able to engage,
it was interactive to
the previous question,
and I was enjoying myself.
And so I'm a big believer
that if most students
are able to fill in their gaps
and feel like they can engage
all of a sudden they
actually will get excited
about that topic.
Now, a very good answer when someone says,
"When will I have to use this?"
Sometimes the teacher we
sometimes hem and haw and say,
"Well, if you become
an engineer you'll..."
And then the student goes,
"Well, I'm not gonna be an engineer."
"Well, if you're going to finance."
"Well, I'm not gonna go into finance."
"Well, if you go into
medicine or medical research."
"Well, I'm not."
And you know...
"Well, if you become a lawyer
you need these critical thinking skills."
And you can imagine it
becomes this kind of duel
(laughs) between the
student and the teacher.
I find just tell them straight up,
the world is gonna evaluate you by this
and it look, you can believe me or not,
but these critical thinking skills
are going be super valuable.
There was one of the early
funders of Khan Academy
he ran a large restaurant chain,
and he told me that he
divides his employees
by folks who understand algebra
and folks who do not understand algebra.
And that doesn't mean that you need to do
a lot of deep algebra if you're
the manager of a restaurant,
or if you're the district manager,
or if you're the head of marketing,
but what that told me and
it makes a lot of sense is,
for him the folks who knew algebra
had the critical thinking
skills to tackle complex things,
simplify them deductively,
make logical deductions about things.
But whenever I tell that story to anyone
who is kind of like,
"When am I gonna need the algebra?"
They're like,
"Oh, wow."
You know, my future bosses (laughs)...
I wanna be... (mumbles)
When they divide the world into
the people who know algebra
and the people who don't know algebra,
and the people who know algebra
get a lot more opportunity
and a lot more income,
I wanna be divided into the
people who know algebra.
And it's also frankly just gonna give you
a lot more confidence in life
because you know that you're gonna be able
to tackle problems and
deductively reason about things.
So from Facebook Jane Molnar asked
"Sal, do you have any tips
for working at a distance
on Khan Academy with
children who cannot yet read,
but are too old for the
preschool Khan Academy?
Thank you."
So Jane, you kind of just
described my youngest child
and what I would encourage is
take a second look at Khan Academy kids.
And the reason why I'm telling you that
is 'cause I recently took a second look
at Khan Academy kids.
The first version of Khan Academy kids
starts with the letters, the numbers,
and it kind of went through the pre-K
and the K and the kindergarten standards.
And my son had already kinda known that
and when I was putting that
in front of him he's like,
"Oh, this is easy, this is baby stuff."
What's cool is in the last month
Khan Academy kids just launched
the first grade standards,
and I'm finding that that is
really hitting the sweet spot
for my five and a half year old
'cause he's learning to read
he's not fluent at reading yet,
and it's really hitting
exactly where he needs to be
and I'm guessing that's where your child
might be ready for as well.
So go on to Khan Academy kids
you can actually change the
grade setting for your child,
and now there's actually teacher accounts
and which you can also access as a parent,
where you can go to your account
and if you click on your username
it'll say become a teacher at Khan,
and you can say you're
teaching first grade.
And then you can actually
assign first grade content
to your child as well.
So, if your child's account
gets turned into a first grade account
then he or she will see
that first grade content
and the system naturally
keeps track of where they are,
and then makes the
recommendations accordingly
across math, reading and writing.
And then if you're a teacher or a parent
you can also direct them
to certain activities.
You can sample them and then direct them.
So I highly take a second look at it
'cause it'll get your child
through the basics of reading.
So the fact that they're not reading yet,
this is definitely going
to be useful for them.
So YouTube, from YouTube, Alan Yab says,
"Hi Sal, what do you think is better
remote learning or in person?"
Well, it's not a comparison
I think they're good at different things.
The ideal is in person,
but what matters, you know...
Let me put it this way,
When you, you know, I remember
my in person college classes
were 300 people in a lecture hall,
or actually, maybe it was a lecture hall
that could fit 300 people,
100 people showed up.
The professor would
kind of give the lecture
essentially read the lecture notes
that he might have been
using for the last 18 years,
and there's like 20 people in the front
who were paying attention
and then there's a group of
people someplace in the middle
or the back and they're trying to stay up,
but they're kind of
dozing off a little bit.
That's not a great in person experience,
and I could imagine a virtual experience
that is at least as good
or better than that.
If you just have a video of that
you're already maybe as good
because you can pause and repeat
and watch it at two X speed.
And then you can imagine a
Zoom session or Google Hangout
where the professor is asking questions,
having a Socratic dialogue,
giving you a challenging problem
and making you work in
groups on that problem
before coming back to the professor.
So that comparison
is a highly not interactive
physical experience
versus a highly interactive
virtual experience,
in that world that virtual is better.
Now, the dream scenario
is a highly interactive
in person experience.
So the ideal experience,
what I want for my children,
what I would want if I'm a student
and frankly what I would want as a teacher
is everyone's in the room,
but it's not just me projecting something
that could be a video,
it's me facilitating, designing,
interactions, dialogue
that's gonna form
deep meaningful connections
with each other.
So that's the real value
of person to person in person interaction.
Now, distance learning is
able to do a few things
that you can't do in person,
if students are traveling,
obviously we're in an
emergency situation right now,
distance learning can be more flexible
around time and space, you
can run a class at 9:00 PM
and it could include people
from all over the country
or all over the world.
So, it does introduce
some flexibility there.
I think the ideal is a is
getting the best of both
so that learning is never
bound by time or space,
but you are for sure getting
that in person socialization,
that in person connection,
which is gonna be very
hard to replace by digital
until we get...
Until virtual reality probably...
We have 50 years of
development of virtual reality
before we can even get close.
So let's see other questions.
Let's see from YouTube.
(mumbles) Kumar asks,
"What are the books behind your back?"
Well, there's all sorts
of books behind my back.
This is actually the walk in closet
where Khan Academy got
started 10 years ago.
It's a nice walk in closet,
it actually has good lighting.
I'm looking at it a window there,
we have a nice little garden out here.
So you shouldn't feel too bad for me
that I'm operating out of a closet.
Yeah, but there's just
a ton of books here.
I mean, these are a lot
of science fiction books,
got the foundation series,
We've got a little Robert Heinlein here
we got all around Ron
Hubbard battlefield Earth.
We've got some Orson
Scott Card, Greg Bear,
up here I have some philosophical
and religious books.
I've got the Bhagavad Gita there,
I've got some passage meditation,
I have a translation of the Quran,
I have...
Let's see, I have a Bible
someplace over here,
so I've got some of that stuff.
Let's see, that's just some nonfiction.
My wife's medical textbooks
for medical school right over here.
So yes, that's the walkthrough
through our closet library.
So from YouTube, A asks,
"Hey Sal, I just want to know
how to organize my time again,
I mean, because of this pandemic
I'm unable to study
like I used to before."
Well A, what I would say is
structure your day as much as possible
and try to Front Load your activity.
So what I do is,
it's a good habit to just
try to wake up everyday
at the same time, my body's so used to it
I don't even need an alarm clock,
my eyes just kind of open
(mumbles) at 7:00 AM.
It might just be because
I'm old now, but...
(mumbles)
And obviously for that to happen
go to sleep at a reasonable time.
And I try to front load, you know,
first thing I try to do things
that give me some easy wins.
I make my bed, and you might say,
"I don't care if my beds made or not."
And I'll say,
"First of all, it is very nice at night
to get into a well made bed
where the sheets are nice
and uncreased and all of that."
It's a nice thing to have in life,
but even more valuable than that
it takes you about three,
four minutes to make the bed.
And by doing that, you're like,
"Okay I got a win, this
is gonna be a good day."
And then I have a little bit
of a ritual in the morning,
I like to meditate at least
15 minutes in the morning,
maybe 30.
That just clears my mind,
it gets me a really
positive frame of mind,
all my stresses seem to kind
of melt away when I do that.
Then I try to do some physical activity,
I mix it up a little bit,
I might go for a mile run,
I might do some handstand push ups,
or go do some pull ups in our garage,
I have a little pull up bar there.
And then I get ready,
and then if I...
Well, COVID or not I try
to do some of the stuff
that takes a little bit
more cognitive work for me.
So, videos take a lot of mental processing
and so I try to do those in the morning,
and I always tell myself,
"Hey Sal, you got 40 minutes
before your next meeting
just try to accomplish
this one or two things,
and if you accomplish that
give yourself a break."
And then I keep doing
that throughout my day.
And then I'm not hard
on myself if by the...
And I used to be frankly, by
the late afternoon if I'm like,
"Hey, you know, I got a lot done Sal,
why don't you go for why
don't you go for a walk,
take it easy a little bit."
I have to admit, before
I had trouble doing that,
I would just keep working,
working, working, working
until I'm just kind of like so brain...
My brain is so fried that
I can't do anything else,
and that's not so healthy
and especially in this time of
COVID and social distancing.
Another thing that I'm doing,
I know this isn't the
question you've asked
you asked about how to use
structure or things like that,
but another thing that I've been doing is
as much as possible when I have meetings,
I try to go on walks.
It just gets fresh air
and it gets my my blood
flowing to the brain.
So let's see, Ricky R asks,
"Hi Sal, any advice on
where I can find a checklist
of what my child should know
before entering fourth grade?"
So, there's two ways to think about it
and actually I just...
That question makes me realize
that I didn't answer an
earlier question about
how do you remediate students
from that teacher who
teaches algebra students.
So today, what I would do
if a student's about
to enter fourth grade,
I would have them either...
I would have them work
on our third grade course
on Khan Academy,
and they can accelerate
by taking the course
challenges in the unit tests,
but if they get through the
third grade course completely,
they're gonna be very
ready for fourth grade.
Even better is if they get
started on the fourth grade
because then when they
see it next year in school
it'll be kind of they've
already been exposed to it,
and so they'll have more of a cushion
in case some of those concepts
are a little bit more
difficult to understand.
Now one thing that I said
I was gonna talk about,
but I didn't but now I will,
is we are actively working on
what we're calling foundations courses.
So there's gonna be a
foundations for fourth grade,
there's gonna be a
foundations for algebra,
a foundations for geometry, a
foundation's for everything,
for all of our courses,
each of our grade levels.
And what that's gonna be is a short course
that covers all of the prerequisite skills
that you need to engage
in that grade level,
and the reason why that's
a little bit different
than just going through
third grade is that
you actually don't need
every third grade standard
to necessarily engage in fourth grade,
and there's actually certain
maybe even second and
first grade standards
that you do need to
engage in fourth grade.
And so this is going to be a new course,
type of course that we're gonna curate.
And you can imagine most fourth graders
might know a lot of that material,
and so they can take the course
challenge and the unit test
to accelerate through it,
but then the material they don't know
they'll be able to fill in those gaps
and then there'll be super
prepared for fourth grade.
So today, use the grade
level before on Khan Academy,
get your kids to master that
and they can accelerate with
course challenges in unit test.
You might also want to
use the arithmetic course,
and hopefully in about two months
expect to see these foundations courses,
which are kind of exactly
what students need
to get to grade level
as quickly as possible
or at least to know...
At least feel good that
they have the foundations
to be prepared for grade
level as quickly as possible.
So from YouTube Quacker Diesels asks,
"Hey Sal, how does the Khan Academy staff
coping up with this crisis?"
It's great question Quacker.
(mumbles)
I would say overall reasonably well,
we were already a reasonably
distributed workforce.
We had about 35, 40% of our team members
were not based in our
office here in California,
and so we always had a...
We were always using Google
Meet and Zoom for our meetings,
and we always, you know,
in almost every meeting we
almost always had someone
who was distributed or remote,
and so that was a pretty
easy transition for us
to stay functional.
We just leaned heavier on those tools.
I think the difficult part is
people are going through stuff,
they're worried about
their family members,
I haven't heard of any
of our team members yet
with a family member who's
gotten very sick from COVID, yet.
Thank goodness, but you can
imagine people are worried.
I think the biggest drain
has been on a lot of parents
of young kids.
I'm in that bucket, but I'm
lucky I have myself, my wife,
my mother in law, we're
all in the house together.
My kids...
As teachers have been
doing an amazing heroic job
at KLS, keeping the kids supported
and keeping them learning.
So I feel very fortunate there,
but we have team members that
they might be a single parent,
they have a two year old
or they have two kids
or they might be (mumbles)
both them and their partner,
but they have two or three young children.
You can imagine it's very hard
to keep the two or three year old occupied
while the same time you're trying to work,
so that has definitely
caused some stress for folks.
And we've been very clear
with our team members
that if you can try to do it, you can.
This is Khan Academy's moment
to step up for the world,
but this is also a time that we, you know,
some of these team members
have done such incredible work
over the years, we're
not going to, you know...
They have to take care of themselves
and their families first and foremost,
but for the most part I
think the Khan Academy team
is doing well, thanks for asking.
So from YouTube.
If YouTube...
Okay, this is a real time math problem.
Avinash Carr says,
"A popular website requires
users to create a password
consisting of digits only.
If no digit may be repeated
and each word, password
must be nine digits long.
How many passwords are possible?"
This is...
I was a little worried,
I thought you're gonna give me a hard one,
but I'm probably jinxing it
because I'm probably gonna
in real time make a mistake, but no.
So if I understand correctly, nine digits,
you're not you can't repeat it.
So the way I think about it,
think about the leftmost digit.
There are 10 points possible digits,
so there's 10 possibilities
for that leftmost one.
And then for the one to the right of that
you've already used one
of the 10 possible digits,
so now you have nine
possibilities for the next one,
and then you have eight
and so it's gonna be 10 times
nine times eight times seven
and so you're gonna do that
all the way down to two.
So, if I did that right it's gonna be...
Because the last one you're
gonna have two digits left
because you're using a nine digits long.
And I'm assuming we're going
with nine digit passwords,
obviously...
Well, I can see how it could be trick
because you say it has to be
at least nine digits long,
so you're saying it
could also be 10 digits.
So if I were to say just a nine digit
how many nine digit passwords are there,
it would be it would be 10 factorial,
and then how many 10
digit passwords are there?
Well, for each of those
nine digit passwords
it would kind of determine
what that last digit has to be.
So, you would then get an extra password
essentially for each of
those nine digit passwords.
So, I think you would get
two times 10 factorial
is the answer,
and you obviously can't have
more than a 10 digit password
'cause you can't reuse the digits.
Don't know if I did that, right.
But here's to making ourselves vulnerable
and answering math questions in real time.
All right. (laughs)
Maybe I'll do one more
question to redeem myself
just in case I made a
careless error on that one.
From Facebook,
And y'all see I'm reading this real time
there's no prep in this,
so y'all are getting me as I am.
So by Enza Charity says,
"Hi Sal, how can I study better
while waking up early in the morning
without getting distracted?
How can I also make my
studying more interesting
while enjoying and understanding?"
With the distraction problem,
well there's a couple of
things, meditation is great.
Your mind just gets a little
bit trained to not get
scatterbrained I guess is
one way to think about it.
I think the morning is
the best time to do it,
try to find a quiet time.
And I would... (mumbles)
We talked about the Pomodoro
Technique in the past,
which is, it's called the
Pomodoro 'cause it's named
after a timer shaped
like a pomodoro tomato.
But give yourself 20 minutes to say
for this 20 minutes I'm gonna focus
and do what I need to do,
and then I'm gonna give
myself a 10 minute break,
20 minutes focus and then
give myself a 10 minute break.
And there's actually
some research on that,
that that tends to ease procrastination
can allow you to get a
little bit more focused,
while also being able to recharge.
You know, how did you make
study more interesting?
What I would say, you have
an opportunity right now.
During the normal school year
you have so many things on your plate
and extracurricular
activities that you're like,
"Oh, I just have to cram this
so that I can do my homework
or so that I can learn for tomorrow."
And so you don't have the time and space
to ponder and to really enjoy the concept.
I hope that now that certain
things have been taken off
of our plates, social things, et cetera.
There's more time to ponder
and the pondering is the fun part.
So when you're reading, you know,
I don't know what you're
trying to study, chemistry,
and you're like,
"Okay, PV equals nRT."
Instead of just memorizing that,
why does that make sense?
All right, well let's just imagine
N represents the number of molecules.
I mean it's measured in moles,
but that's just a quantity of molecules.
R is just a constant (mumbles)
to make the unit's workout,
and then T is temperature.
So the number of molecules
and the temperature,
see the more molecules,
the higher temperature,
they're bouncing around more vigorously.
Yeah, either if I hold volume constant
it's gonna create more pressure,
or if I hold pressure constant
in order to do that I'd
have to expand the volume.
Or if I hold pressure constant
the balloon would blow up so
to speak, and you're like,
"Oh, that makes a lot of
sense, this is intuitive.
Of course PV equals nRT."
And then it becomes exciting
and then when you look around the world
all sorts of things make sense,
and you start to see it in the real world.
I remember the famously
Tom Brady in Deflategate,
there was this debate
about whether his footballs
were deflated inappropriately.
That was actually a PV equals nRT problem,
and I made some videos on that
and it's still under debate,
but you start seeing these things
that you think are these
random academic formulas,
you start seeing them in the world
when you start pondering them,
and you start making connections
to other concepts in your life.
You know, what I remind every student is
what you get to learn
today on Khan Academy,
from your textbook from your teacher,
most of these things are the culmination
of someone's life work
or often times the combination
of many people's life works
over hundreds of years
and you get the answer.
Isaac Newton, Marie Curie,
they would have killed
to have your physics or
chemistry or biology textbook,
it would have saved them a
lot of work, and you get it.
And so realize that,
realize that there are profound answers.
I mean, the nature of DNA,
these are mind blowing things
that Watson and Crick would have loved,
Mendel would have loved
to get their hands on
and you get those answers.
So look at it in that lens
you're getting the answers,
And do them justice, think
about them, ponder them,
don't just try to memorize
and regurgitate it for the next test.
So that's my advice, And I
realized I'm all out of time.
This was a fun one, and I...
Oh, (mumbles) given that this is the end
of Teacher Appreciation Week,
I wanted to make sure that
we give a special shout out
to all the teachers everywhere.
So I will see you on Monday,
but we're gonna go out
with a special thank you
to all of the amazing
teachers around the world,
from our team at Khan Academy.
See y'all on Monday.
- To Mrs. Cordell, my
fourth grade teacher.
- To miss Peterson.
- To Mr. Gobet.
- To Mr. Jones.
- To Ms. Wolf.
- To Mrs. Young.
- Mr. Chavez.
- Mr. Bodie, fifth and sixth grade.
- To Mr. Blake.
- To Mr. Lester.
- To Mr. Howard.
- To Mr. Zarnecki.
- Dr. John.
- To Mrs. Alvarado.
- To Gail Wills and Janice Souza.
- You know, Mrs. Mayhew.
- To my high school humanities teacher.
- To Mrs. valentine my
kindergarten teacher.
(upbeat music)
- Who taught me how to analyze
literature and to write.
- Who first introduced me.
to the magic of TV and film production.
- Who helped me find my voice in writing.
- Who encouraged me to
write my first program.
- Who helped me figure out
how to think about and what
I think about so many
different things in the world.
- Who brought so much love
and joy into the classroom.
- And demanded excellence
while treating us with respect.
- Who helped me get over
my fear of public speaking.
- Who gave me a book, began my
love of science and fiction.
- Who believe in us even
when we blew everything up.
- Who taught me the value
of telling stories to teach
and listening to other people's stories.
- Who is such an amazing woman
I named my daughter after her.
(upbeat music)
- And for making us all
feel special all the time.
- And you were exceedingly
patient with me.
- For helping me discover
my love for writing.
- For pushing me to always be
the best version of myself.
- And for teaching me that I could
accomplish anything I put my mind to.
- For telling me I was good at math.
- For making sure that I knew
I could do accelerated work.
- For encouraging my love
of reading and writing.
- For making me feel
welcome in her classroom
as a recent immigrant
to the United States.
- For inspiring me to become a
kindergarten teacher in turn.
You've touched so many lives,
both your students and
your students, students
more than you'll ever know.
(piano music)
- Thanks Mrs. Mayhew.
- Thank you Mr. Blake.
- Thank you Mr. Chavez.
- Thank you Mr. Gobet.
- Thank you Mrs. Cordell.
- Thank you Mrs. Graham.
- Thank you Mr. Lester.
- Thank you, Mr. Howen.
- You've made a huge impact
on my life and so many others,
thank you.
- Thank you.
(piano music)